man denkt sich um
wegrannte kleine am
17 schild ist
jeden morgen um acht jetzt kaffee
gemacht
morgens fiel um neun geht wie in die
scheune war ganz still und films hat sie
heult und steht
fortan um 11 doch dann wird und will
sich bei next und nicht nur die kinder
kommt dass dich
lustig sieht und wie verzaubert
ist verliert bank
bekomme ich dann wird plötzlich her
dass mich so ein bisschen an die kleine
hexe
und das ganze erinnert mich an meine
kindheit im ich habe schon als kind den
klassiker von otfried preußler die
kleine hexe gelesen wahrscheinlich
kennen ihres buch auch und jetzt wird
dieses buch zum ersten mal verfilmt und
kommt ab dem ersten 2 in die kinos und
heute startet sogar einen
weltrekordversuch denn heute sollen alle
als hexe oder als zauberer verkleidet in
die kinos gehen und somit beim
weltrekordversuch mitmachen das heißt
wenn ihr heute zeit habt dann geht schon
mal in die kinos und macht mit und ich
habe aktuell zum film anlass zum
filmstart diese torte gebacken der
hexenkessel mit dem samira schon ein
bisschen gezaubert hat was ist ein
hexenkessel
das klingt furchtbar bei unserem keine
frösche beide träumen sondern ein
bisschen himbeeren himbeer wackelpudding
schmeckt uns beiden persönlich etwas
pech los geht es mit der torte ich habe
bisher so ein bisschen was vorbereitet
und zwar habe ich die tortenböden schon
vorgebacken insgesamt vier stück zweimal
mit dem durchmesser 20 zentimeter und
zweimal mit dem durchmesser 24 cm und
die tortenböden habe ich bereits gestern
gebacken damit sie heute wirklich schön
stabil sind und ich sehr gut durch
schneiden kann und das rezept findet ihr
dann in diesem video was ich hier
verlinken wert außerdem habe ich noch
eine garage vorbereitet und bei diesem
rezept nehme ich jetzt eine zart peter k
nach zum bestreichen der torte und auch
dieses rezept findet ihr bereits in
meinem cache basics jetzt geht es weiter
mit den blow bläschen die kleine hexe
kocht nämlich eine richtig tolle sache
und die ist bei uns nicht grün-rot
typischen grünen sondern bei uns erlebt
und ich verwende jetzt hier für euch im
web-browser ihr könnt aber auch zum
beispiel einen saft nehmen oder einen
sirup mit wasser vermischen dann müsst
ihr einfach schauen was euch am besten
schmeckt dafür brauche ich einen liter
wasser oder saft ich verfeinere das
wasser jetzt mit etwas himbeer brause
ich brauche 30 gramm agata und nach
berlin zucker und lebensmittel verpasste
gewitzt zuerst einmal das wasser in den
topf und
ihr habt jetzt auch schon gemerkt ich
bin der jetzt in wackelpudding was es ja
am ende ist mit etwas engagement
tine und für den geschmack kommt bis in
himbeer browser rein und dann müsste
einfach ein bisschen abspecken dass es
genug ist also noch bisschen zucker
dazugeben wenn ihr möchtet hier kommt
jetzt das acker mit rein
etwas farbe
so dass wir ein schönes pink gehalten
[Musik]
das lasse ich die masse aufkochen und an
zwei minuten sprudelnd kochen damit dass
aka aka auch wirken kann und der
wackelpudding später auf west wird
[Musik]
so sieht die masse jetzt aus die ist
natürlich noch richtig heiß zum
einfüllen verwende ich jetzt einerseits
einen kleinen bug ring also sich einfach
einmal mit etwa 12 cm durchmesser ihr
könnt aber auch zum beispiel in
schälchen nehmen was sie aber vorher mit
frischhaltefolie auskleiden ist das hier
wird dann die frucht einlage für die
torte und für die torte obendrauf als
deko brauche ich noch diese blogger
bläschen und dafür habe ich hier diese
deko halbschalen die gibt's im
bastelladen und die werde ich jetzt
befüllen und hier habe ich noch eine
silikonform und zwar ist es so eine
eiswürfel vor und da werde ich kleinere
bläschen reinmachen jetzt kann ich
zuerst einmal die hier befüllen
[Musik]
jetzt lasse ich die masse ganz kurz ein
bisschen abkühlen daher habe ich jetzt
hier so ein kühl pad darunter dann wenn
ich das jetzt so ihnen diese backform
ein leser dann läuft einfach unten alles
raus und als kleiner tipp wenn ihr auch
hier in kühl thema drunter habt wird die
masse innerhalb von ein bis zwei minuten
schön fest ihr könnt wieder weiter
füllen und daher ruhig ist hier noch ein
bisschen unser bald lauwarm ist die sich
nur schicht rein und wer möchte kann
dann und parke vorne hin wer noch mit
rein geben sie dann auch ganz toll aus
in wackelpudding und wenn ihr möchtet
dass die dann in der schicht innen schön
fliesen und schwimmen und schön stehen
bleiben dann müsste einfach schicht für
schicht ein bisschen einfüllen
einfrieren wiedereinführung wieder
einfrieren
[Musik]
für die creme brauche ich 500 gramm
sahne 500 gramm magerquark 500 gramm
fisch käse etwas sonderbar zwei
teelöffel extrakt und 150 gramm
puderzucker für die creme verliere ich
jetzt den frischkäse gemeinsam mit dem
quark vanille extrakt und puderzucker in
eine rührschüssel und hier könnt ihr
jetzt gerne auch noch lebensmittel
verpasste dazugeben und sobald die
zutaten verrührt sind kommt jetzt noch
langsam die sahne mit dazu und das
sommerbad so dass die creme schon fest
wird jetzt kann die torte schon befüllt
werden und dafür nehme ich hier ein
kleines kickboxer 20 zentimeter im
durchmesser und damit die torte da nicht
runter rutscht ein bisschen creme drauf
die habe ich jetzt bereits in einen
spritzbeutel gefüllt mit einer großen
loch thüle das hilft mir einfach beim
einführen
und ich finde es richtig schön wie man
diese kleine schokostückchen hier sieht
und wer möchte kann jetzt den boden noch
trinken mit einer marmelade zum beispiel
ich nehme jetzt hier aprikose die habe
ich jetzt vorher erwärmt und die hat
kein stückchen drin und ist fein
passiert ihr könnt aber auch himbeer zum
beispiel nehmen
[Musik]
hier kommt jetzt eine schicht creme
drauf nicht ganz bis zum rand
bei der creme ist auch wichtig dass sie
später nicht in kontakt mit dem vom land
kommt daher kommt das später auch die
garage aus warum
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier direkt der größere
boden drauf damit die torte schönbeck
wird
[Musik]
damit die torte beim befüllen mehr
stabilität habt spritze ich jetzt auch
gleich die kanal strom herum
und jetzt kommt in diese schicht ein
kleines loch und da kommt die frucht
einlage rhein und die anderen böden muss
jetzt auch ausstechen damit sie einfach
drum herum passen
[Musik]
und bei der letzten schicht mache ich
nur noch darauf einfach wegen der
stabilität
[Musik]
ich glaube so ein bisschen was kann man
schon erkennen die torte muss jetzt so
erstmal in den kühlschrank für
mindestens ein bis zwei stunden damit
sie schön fest wird die garage fest wird
und danach kann ich die torte in form
schneiden wichtig ist jetzt im prinzip
nur das oben die frucht anlage ein
bisschen tiefer sitzt sondern eben auch
eine schöne kessel formen steht
jetzt ist die torte schön fest und ich
kann sie zu schneiden so dass er
aussieht wie ein hexenkessel das heißt
immer mit einem messer hier ansetzen und
einfach ein bisschen rund schneiden
[Musik]
und jetzt nehme ich die garage und
streiche die erste schicht garage um die
torte und kann immer wieder etwas
wegschneiden bis mir die form am ende
gefehlt
[Musik]
jetzt gefällt mir die torte ganz kurz
und jetzt kommt gleich die zweite
schicht danach darauf die das ganze aus
glätten soll der top wir sehr im bus ein
sondertopf das heißt da ist sehr alt und
verbeult und darf auch ruhig alt
aussehen daher muss auch jetzt nicht
symmetrisch aussehen doch mal ne beule
und stelle haben ja also kommt jetzt
kurz in den kühlschrank und dann kann
ich sie glatt streichen
die zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt um ein
bisschen dicke vorzubereiten jetzt
kommen die zwei griffe dran dafür habe
ich schon schwarze modell der schokolade
weich geknetet und formen daraus eine
lange rolle
und jetzt nehme ich einen ausstecher ihr
könnt aber auch im glas nehmen und es
einmal darum herum legen also dass es
eben eine runde griff wird
und dann schön gerade wegschneiden und
zusammenkleben mit essbarem kleben
[Musik]
und die kann ich jetzt einfach trocknen
lassen und jetzt noch die kette formen
und dafür nehme ich jetzt einfach blüten
passte damit die schneller austrocknet
und werde ist daraus eine lange dünne
rolle machen
[Musik]
und jetzt ist nur wichtig die
kettenglieder immer gleich krank zu
machen ich werde jetzt auch nicht zu
kurz schneiden damit so schön groß sind
die ketten werden dann auch
zusammengeklebt und ich mache das jetzt
so ich mache jetzt etwa 20 stück die ich
bereits zusammenkleben lasst sie
trocknen und die nächsten werde ich dann
zum verbinden benutzen
[Musik]
jetzt ist die tische in kiel und jetzt
willst du mich von da eingedeckt hat die
torte bereits auf eine holzplatte
gesetzt und habe den von dort habe jetzt
schwarzen von dort kommen weiß geknetet
und ganz dünn ausgerollt und jetzt wird
die torte eingekleidet und damit davon
dort an der garage hält habe ich jetzt
mit etwas back transport eingesprüht
[Musik]
hier hinten will dass ich jetzt einen
aber das ist völlig okay das ist dann
einfach die rückseite der torte
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich mit den fingern sind von
dorn bisschen glatt streichen und dann
die reste auch noch wegnehmen
[Musik]
jetzt geht es an die brühe damit sich
hier innen auch die frucht anlage gleich
sichtbar wird und auch die kugeln
sichtbar werden habe ich jetzt hier ein
bisschen pinkfarben und von dort habe
ich einfach erdbeer genommen also etwa
von dauer und pink eingefärbt jetzt muss
ich hier einfach so eine kleine basis
schaffen so dass man die farbe eben auch
im anschluss erkennt als einfach ein
bisschen von dort nehmen und hier dran
zu drücken
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt noch mal ein bisschen
wackelpudding gemacht und den streiche
ich jetzt hier drauf zum einen dass es
ein bisschen glänzt und zum anderen
passt dann auch zur erfüllung und den
rest gieße ich dann hier oben drauf habe
ich natürlich ein bisschen abkühlen
lassen
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die zwei griffe hier
rechts und links ankleben und das mache
ich jetzt hier mit hilfe eines weiteren
stückes habe ich jetzt einfach ein
bisschen rechteckig ausgerollt und
ausgeschnitten da kommt ein bisschen
kleber drauf
und dann wird es einfach drüber geklebt
und jetzt habe ich hier eine kleine
spritztour und kann hier einfach so 23
löcher rein stechen dann sieht es aus
als wären die sunniten drin
[Musik]
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr den
hexenkessel doch ein bisschen
schockieren mit etwas pulver farbe ich
nehme jetzt hier schwarz braun und ein
bisschen kupfer
[Musik]
jetzt wird die torte fertig dekoriert
dafür nehme ich jetzt diese kleinen
bläschen
auspackte pudding nur die lassen sich
auch ganz gut raus lösen
und damit sie eben auch so aus als wird
so ein bisschen kochen
und die auster silikonform lassen sich
ganz leicht ausdrücken
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich noch die kette ankleben
die es wirklich ganz toll getrocknet
dass man nur ganz vorsichtig sein was
nicht bricht und die gebe ich jetzt hier
an den henkel dran
[Musik]
und verletzte finish habe ich hier noch
mal ein bisschen von dem wackelpudding
erwärmt und geht es jetzt ganz
vorsichtig nochmal drüber man sieht das
alles ein bisschen verbundene aus
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt unser hexenkessel
ausgefeilte den
komfort wie die torte jetzt auch
veranstalten kommen wir noch zum
gewinnspiel und zwar jetzt richtig tolle
pakete für gewinnen in den paketen sind
enthalten jeweils zwei kinofreikarten
für den kinofilm die kleine hexe einmal
der roman die kleine hexe zum lesen ein
activity booklet mit vielen spielen und
basteltipps magische stifter und
brausepulver und beim gewinnspiel könnt
ihr mitmachen indem wir uns einen
kommentar unter dem video hinterlasst
und zwar würde ich gerne wissen was
würdet ihr denn tun wenn ihr zaubern
könnte was würdest du tun wenn du
zaubern können dachte ich hätte die welt
verschieben
ich auch schon ich würde alles böse von
der welt löschen und ich würde gerne
einmal fliegen auf dem hexenbesen
klar dass irgendwann
schauen worden
du bist anschneiden kommen schnell
zusammen
marx
ist immer die frage wo schneidet man die
torte anschneiden hier okay
wir steigen jetzt ein ganz großes stück
schon gespannt
vielleicht findet auch
kleine mit fresh & vision
und krebs und fisch folgt
so sieht sie aus
cool oder
ich mag es mal probieren
oder sehr
wichtig
und gut ich finde es richtig cool aus
und schmeckt auch wirklich sehr gut ich
habe vorhin auch schon ein paar sachen
probiert falls ihr das rezept auch nach
machen möchtet warte wir machen gleich
nur fotos dann schaut auf meinem blog
vorbei aufs ellis blog.de wir freuen uns
auf jeden fall auf euer feedback auf
eure zauberkünste bin ich auch schon
gespannt also was würdet ihr tun wenn
ihre zaubern würde falls ihr den film
anschauen wollt wie gesagt ab dem ersten
februar in allen kinos wir schauen uns
den auch auf jeden fall an geld und
unser zeug ganz viel spaß gemacht und
wir sehen uns wieder beim nächsten mal
da kann eigentlich auch den papa
verzaubern
echt was würdest du denn da machen
ein frosch und da muss ich ihn küssen
sondern wird er wieder zum grinsen
[Musik]
wie soll
das erste akw praxis